- (beep) me that's good.
- [Selorm] It is really good.
- Wow, holy (beep).
(jazz music)
- Hi how you doing?
- [Ali] Hi!
- [Kuwilileni] Hey!
- My name's Simon, I have been drafted in
to be your bartender for today.
What is a favorite go-to for you?
- Anything with, like, herbs.
So like fresh ginger.
- I love all of these things right here.
(Simon laughs)
- I do like rum.
I do like tequila.
And whiskey.
- I know you're having
a good day or a bad day.
(both laugh)
- I typically don't really
go for the sweet cocktail.
- If you have tequila I'm sold.
I will drink it.
Maybe I will drink way too many.
But tequila it is.
- Gin and tonics.
And I like tiki drinks.
- What does mine say about me?
- Party, fiery, dance on the table.
- Okay, oh (laughs).
- 19 years old.
(Simon laughs)
- My favorite thing about
really good cocktails
are they almost remind
you of medicine in a way.
- [Ali] Oh my God.
- Like a good salve.
- [Kuwilileni] Or like,
- [Ali] Yes.
- [Kuwilileni] something
along those lines.
- I love those big ice cubes (laughs)
- [Simon] I love these.
- Did you hand-cut these below?
(jazz music)
Mine smells like springtime.
- [Ali] This is what you drink
when you can afford a boat.
- [Kuwilileni] Yes, I agree.
- This smells like the Titanic.
(laughs)
- The classy part.
- [Selorm] Oh it looks
so nice, that color.
Ta-da.
(Simon laughs)
- You just gonna dunk your head in that
and drink the whole thing?
- I think so.
- I'm actually starting
to salivate a little bit.
This is kind of like a
Pavlovian experiment.
Oh it smells so (beep) good, oh God.
(Simon laughs)
- [Garrett] It does look healthy
with those cucumber sticks in there.
- It does.
Oh gosh, this tastes like summer.
- [Simon] This maybe is
daytime drinking for you.
- [Garrett] Yeah no this
feel definitely like--
(Shila and Simon laugh)
the sun is beating down.
It's so refreshing.
- Oh my God!
- Oh my God.
- Oh wow.
- Ooh what?
- Man, nothing but
quality for these drinks.
- That's fancy.
- So it has like a citrus-y start.
But then it has this like creamy finish.
But you can still taste the whiskey.
Which is, I don't know how you did it.
- It's not like overpoweringly sweet.
Because the watermelon's
still put a lot of, like,
water in it.
- I think this is my
favorite Negroni of all time.
Which is crazy--
- I agree.
- Because I've never had
one with tequila ormesco.
- I feel like, yeah,
no it's really cool this drink takes you
like out of this world.
Like I feel like I'm not at a bar.
Like I'm at, you know,
some holiday vacation
drinkin' this nice drink.
And it's so smooth and calming.
And I just, I don't know, I feel at peace.
Maybe it's the quila talking but.
- You're a wizard sir.
- You are a wizard.
- You're a warlock back there.
- You feel so special and pampered
when you have like a drink
that's catered just for you.
- You've left me speechless.
(laughs)
- [Kuwilileni] I love it.
- I am already a little tipsy!
- Yeah it's like wooh!
- I usually don't drink at noon.
- No.
(upbeat music)